>>> 2021, THE YEAR THE MEDIA AND
THE WORLD TRIED TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL.
THE PANDEMIC IS NOW A SUBJECT OF
SCRIPTED DRAMAS AND MOVIES,
HELPING US PROCESS IT.
BUT IT'S NOT OVER YET.
AND SOME THINGS HAVE CHANGED
FOREVER.
SO HERE ARE OUR TOP-TEN MEDIA
STORIES OF THE YEAR.
NUMBER 10, DEPLATFORMING DONALD
TRUMP.
TWITTER PERMANENTLY BANNING THE
PRESIDENT, JUST DAYS AFTER THE
CAPITOL INSURRECTION, WHILE
FACEBOOK GAVE HIM A TIME-OUT.
>> OUR BREAKING NEWS THIS HOUR,
FACEBOOK SAYS FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP WILL NOT BE ALLOWED
BACK ON ITS PLATFORM UNTIL AT
LEAST JANUARY 7th, 2023.
>> WHILE TRUMP CRIED CENSORSHIP,
SOCIAL MEDIA CEOs ARE JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHERE TO
DRAW THE LINE.
NUMBER 9, TV NEWS TURNOVER,
CHRIS CUOMO OUT AT CNN AFTER
TEXT MESSAGES SHOWED HOW HE
HELPED HIS GOVERNOR BROTHER
FIGHT SEXUAL ALLEGATIONS BOTH
COMOS ARE OUT OF JOBS.
AND "NEWSROOM" NBC, RACHEL
MADIEU PREPARING TO LEAVE.
AND NBC REPLACING BRIAN WILLIAMS
WHO SIGNED OFF IN DECEMBER
WITHOUT A WARNING.
>> FOR THE FIRST TIME IN 62
YEARS MY BIGGEST WORRY IS FOR MY
COUNTRY.
>> OVER AT FOX, A DIFFERENT
DEPARTURE, LOU DODD OUT, AFTER A
DEFAMATION LAWSUIT.
AT THE END OF THE YEAR, CHRIS
WALLACE ANNOUNCED THAT HE'S
LEAVING FOX ON HIS OWN TERMS.
NUMBER 8, OPRAH'S BOMBSHELL
INTERVIEW WITH PRINCE HARRY AND
MEGHAN MARKLE.
WITH THE DUCHESS OF SUSSEX
CITING CONCERNS ABOUT THE BABY'S
SKIN COLOR.
>> I JUST CAN'T WANT TO BE ALIVE
ANYMORE.
>> FALLOUT FROM THE INTERVIEW
RIPPLED ACROSS SOCIAL MEDIA WHEN
A CO-WORKER CALLED OUT PIERS
MORGAN FOR HIS ANTI-MEAGEN RANTS
HE STORMED OFF.
>> YOU CONTINUED TO TRASH HER.
>> NO, NO.
>> SORRY.
>> NO, NO --
>> SEE YOU LATER, SORRY, CAN'T
DO THIS.
>> ABSOLUTELY DIABOLICAL
BEHAVIOR.
>> HE THEN LEFT THE NETWORK.
AS FOR HARRY AND MEAGEN, THEY'RE
MAKING PODCASTS AND TV SHOWS
WHICH LEADS ME TO NUMBER 7,
GIANTS TRYING TO GET EVEN BIGGER
INVESTING MORE IN STREAMING TO
KEEP YOU SUBSCRIBED.
STREAMING TO SPIN OFF
WARNERMEDIA INCLUDING CNN AND
COMBINE IT WITH DISCOVERY.
THE NEWSSTAND-ALONE COMPANY WILL
TAKE SHAPE IN MID-2022 GOING
HEAD TO HEAD WITH NETFLIX AND
DISNEY.
IN 2021, SQUID GAMES AND TED
LASSO WON AWARDS AND PUTTING
MOVIES LIKE "BLACK WIDOW" BOTH
ON STREAMING AND THEATERS AT THE
SAME.
WHEN DISNEY DID THAT, SCARLETT
JOHANSSON SHOCKED HOLLYWOOD FOR
BREACH OF CONTRACT SHOWING THE
RULES ARE REWRITTEN EVERY DAY.
NUMBER 6, DARING REPORTING FROM
AFGHANISTAN, AS THE TALIBAN
APPROACHED ON KABUL, AND THE
U.S. WITHDRAWAL BECAME CHAOTIC
REPORTERS BECAME THE EYES AND
EARS OF THE WORLD.
>> JUST TOLD ME TO STAND ASIDE
BECAUSE I'M A WOMAN.
>> CNN'S ARWA DAMON EARNED
PRAISE FROM FELLOW JOURNALISTS.
BEHIND THE SCENES, THEY WORKED
TO HELP ENDANGERED REPORTERS AND
OTHER AFGHANS WHO WORKED WITH
WESTERN MEDIA.
THE OTHER REPORTERS WHO REMAIN
THERE FACED A HOSTILE CLIMATE
WHICH BRINGS ME TO NUMBER 5, THE
CONTINUING CRACKDOWN ON GLOBAL
PRESS FREEDOM.
IN HONG KONG, POLICE RAIDED A
PRO-DEMOCRACY NEWSPAPER IN JUNE,
ARRESTING TOP EDITORS.
A MONTH BEFORE
A DISSIDENT BELARUSIAN
JOURNALIST ARRESTED AFTER HIS
FLIGHT WAS FORCED DOWN IN A
STATE-SPONSORED HIJACKING.
>> HAVE WE SEEN ANYTHING LIKE
THIS?
>> NO IS THE SHORT ANSWER.
>> COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD
ARE ROLLING BACK THE RIGHTS OF
REPORTERS AND SOMETIMES BRAZEN
WAYS.
THE COMMITTEE TO PROTECT
JOURNALISTS SAYS A RECORD HIGH
NUMBER OF REPORTERS ARE BEHIND
BARS NOW WITH CHINA BEING THE
WORST JAILER.
>>> NUMBER FOUR, THE WOKE WARS.
IT'S AN AWAKENING OVER RACIAL
AND SOCIAL INJUSTICE TO SOME
BAUN OVERREACTION TO OTHERS.
IS IT CANCEL CULTURE OR
CONSEQUENCE CULTURE?
AND WHATEVER IT'S CALLED, HAS IT
GONE TOO FAR?
THESE DEBATES RAGED ACROSS MEDIA
ALL YEAR.
>> IT WILL EVENTUALLY GET TO
STRAIGHT WHITE MEN ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO TALK.
>> THIS IS CALLED A PURGE.
IT'S A MENTALITY THAT BELONGS IN
STALIN'S RUSSIA.
>> CANCELING DR. SEUSS ISN'T
STUPID.
IT'S INTENTIONAL.
>> DR. SEUSS WASN'T CANCELED.
HIS LEGACY COMPANY DECIDED TO
STOP PUBLISHING A FEW TITLES
THAT HAD RACIST IMAGERY.
BUT FREE SPEECH ISSUES ARE REAL.
AND ALTERNATIVES ARE EMERGING
FOR PEOPLE WHO WANT TO BYPASS
TRADITIONAL BOOK PUBLISHERS,
NEWSPAPERS AND OTHER
GATEKEEPERS.
WRITERS ARE FLOCKING TO SUBSTACK
AND LAUNCHING NEWSLETTERS, A NEW
MODEL THAT BRINGS FRESH DEBATES
OVER FREE SPEECH.
>>> JANUARY 6th DENIALISM.
THE BIG LIE ABOUT TRUMP WINNING
THE ELECTION LED TO THE BIG
DENY.
DESPERATE ATTEMPTS TO RESIST.
>> THEY DON'T LIKE TERRORISTS.
THEY LOOK LIKE TOURISTS.
>> THAT'S FOX'S HIGHEST RATED
STAR WHILE COMMENTATORS STOKED
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, RIGHT WING
MEDIA BARELY COVERS THE REAL
NEWS ABOUT THE INSURRECTION'S
AFTERMATH.
OR NEW EFFORTS TO SUBVERT
DEMOCRACY AT THE STATE LEVEL.
WHAT WE'RE LOSING IN AMERICA IS
A SENSE OF SHARED REALITY, BUT
THE BIG LIE MAY COST ITS
CRUSADERS.
>> BREAKING JUST A SHORT TIME
AGO, FOX FACING A $1.6 BILLION
LAWSUIT ACCUSED OF SPREADING
ELECTION LIES.
>> AND THAT WAS JUST THE
BEGINNING.
TWO VOTING TECH COMPANIES HAVE
FILTD DEFAMATION SUITS AGAINST
FOX NEWS AND OTHER NETWORKS AND
A SERIES OF BLOCKBUSTER BOOKS
CONTINUE TO REVEAL WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED DURING TRUMP'S FINAL
DAYS IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
NUMBER TWO, THE FACEBOOK
RECKONING.
A WHISTLEBLOWER WAS HEARD AROUND
THE WORLD, FIRST THROUGH THE
FACEBOOK FILES.
A SERIES OF "WALL STREET
JOURNAL" FILES BASED ON LEAKS
FROM INSIDE FACEBOOK.
THEN THE SOURCE, FRANCES HAUGEN
STEPPED FORWARD.
>> I BELIEVE FACEBOOK'S PRODUCTS
HARM CHILDREN, STOKE DIVISION
AND WEAKEN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THE COMPANY'S LEADERSHIP KNOWS
HOW TO MAKE FACEBOOK AND
INSTAGRAM SAVER BUT WON'T MAKE
THE NECESSARY CHANGES BECAUSE
THEY HAVE PUT THEIR ASTRONOMICAL
PROFITS BEFORE PEOPLE.
>> HAUGEN ALLEGED THE COMPANY'S
OWN RESEARCH SHOWED ITS
PLATFORMS CAN BE TOXIC FOR
CHILDREN AND SOCIETY WRIT LARGE.
BUT WITH THE COMPANY FAILING TO
TAKE ACTION, THE CEO MARK
ZUCKERBERG PUSHED BACK SAYING
MANY OF HER CLAIMS DIDN'T MAKE
SENSE.
BUT HAUGEN GAVE NEW MOMENTUM TO
GOVERNMENTS THAT WANT TO REIN IN
SOCIAL MEDIA.
ANTI-SOCIAL MEDIA WAS A THROUGH
LINE FOR THE ENTIRE YEAR.
BRINGING US TO THE NUMBER ONE
MEDIA STORY OF 2021.
THE VACCINE DISINFORMATION
DIVIDE.
RELIABLE INFO ABOUT COVID-19
VACCINES HELPED PEOPLE GET
VAXXED AND PROTECTED.
BUT ANTI-VAX LIES AND
DISTORTIONS WENT VIRAL FROM
FACEBOOK TO FOX IN WAYS THAT
WORSENED THE PANDEMIC'S TERRIBLE
TOLL.
THE RIGHT WING MEDIA MACHINE
TOOK CONSPIRACY THEORIES FROM
THE FRINGES AND MOVED THEM TO
THE MAINSTREAM.
>> RADICAL LEFT WING FANATICS
BENT ON FORCING EACH AND EVERY
AMERICAN TO GET THEMSELVES
INJECTED WITH AN EXPERIMENTAL,
UNPROVEN DRUG.
>> Reporter: FOX NEWS DEMONIZED
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI.
>> THIS IS WHAT PEOPLE SAY TO
ME.
THAT HE DOESN'T REPRESENT
SCIENCE TO THEM.
HE REPRESENTS JOSEPH MANGALA.
AND THE ANTI-SCIENCE RHETORIC
COST LIVES.
SEVERAL RIGHT WING RADIO HOSTS
WHO RESISTED VACCINES DIED OF
COVID.
TV STARS WHO CLAIMED TO RESPECT
THEIR AUDIENCE ACTUALLY PUT THEM
AT RISK.
BIG TECH PLATFORMS SAID THEY
TRIED TO CLEAN UP THE GARBAGE,
BUT THE VACCINE DIVIDE IS A SAD
REFLECTION OF A CHOOSE YOUR OWN
NEWS CULTURE.
IT'S INCUMBENT